Hi.
In this problem we'll work
through an example of
calculating a distribution for
a minute variable using the
method of derived
distributions.
So in general, the process
goes as follows.
We know the distribution for
some random variable X and
what we want is the distribution
for another
random variable of Y, which is
somehow related to X through
some function g.
So Y is a g of X.
And the steps that we follow--
we can actually just kind
of summarize them
using this four steps.
The first step is to write out
the CDF of Y. So Y is thing
that we want.
And what we'll do is we'll
write out the CDF first.
So remember the CDF is just
capital F of y, y is the
probability that random variable
Y is less than or
equal to some value, little y.
The next thing we'll do is,
we'll use this relationship
that we know, between Y and X.
And we'll substitute in,
instead of writing the random
variable Y In here, we'll
write it in terms of X. So we'll
plug in for-- instead of
Y, we'll plug-in X. And we'll
use this function g in order
to do that.
So what we have now is that up
to here, we would have that
the CDF of Y is now the
probability that the random
variable X is less than or equal
to some value, little y.
Next what we'll do is we'll
actually rewrite this
probability as a CDF of
X. So the CDF of X,
remember, would be--
F of x is that the probability
of X is less than or equal to
some little x.
And then once we have that,
if we differentiate this--
when we differentiate the CDF of
X, we get the PDF of X. And
what we presume is that we
know this PDF already.
And from that, what we get is,
when we differentiate this
thing, we get the PDF of Y. So
through this whole process
what we get is, we'll get the
relationship between the PDF
of Y and the PDF of X. So that
is the process for calculating
the PDF of Y using X.
So let's go into our
specific example.
In this case, what we're told
is that X, the one that we
know, is a standard normal
random variable.
Meaning that it's mean
0 and variance 1.
And so we know the
form of the PDF.
The PDF of x is this, 1 over
square root of 2 pi e to the
minus x squared over 2.
And then the next thing that
we're told is this
relationship between X and Y. So
what we're told is, if X is
negative, then Y is minus X.
If X is positive, then Y is
the square root of X. So
this is a graphical its
representation of the
relationship between X and Y.
All right, so we have everything
that we need.
And now let's just go through
this process and calculate
what the PDF of Y is.
So the first thing we do is we
write out the PDF of Y. So the
PDF of Y is what
we've written.
It's the probability that the
random variable Y is less than
or equal to some little y.
Now the next step that we do is
we have to substitute in,
instead of in terms of Y, we
want to substitute it in terms
of X. Because we actually know
stuff about X, but we don't
know anything about Y. So what
is the probability that Y, the
random variable Y, is
less than or equal
to some little y?
Well, let's go back to this
relationship and see if we can
figure that out.
So let's pretend that here
is our little y.
Well, if the random variable
Y is less than or equal to
little y, it has to
be underneath
this horizontal line.
And in order for it to be
underneath this horizontal
line, that means that X has
to be between this range.
And what is this range?
This range goes from minus
Y to Y squared.
So why is that?
It's because in this portion X
and Y are related as, Y is
negative X and here it's Y is
square root of X. So if X is Y
squared, then Y would be Y. If
X is negative Y, then Y would
be Y. All right, so this
is the range that
we're looking for.
So if Y, the random variable
Y is less than or equal to
little y, then this is the same
as if the random variable
X is between negative
Y and Y squared.
So let's plug that in.
This is the same as the
probability that X is between
negative Y and Y squared.
So those are the first
two steps.
Now the third step is, we
have to rewrite this
as the CDF of x.
So right now we have it in terms
of a probability of some
event related to X. Let's
actually transform that to be
explicitly in terms of the CDF
of X. So how do we do that?
Well, this is just the
probability that X is within
some range.
So we can turn that into the
CDF by writing it as a
difference of two CDFs.
So this is the same as the
probability that X is less
than or equal to Y squared minus
the probability that X
is less than or equal
to negative Y.
So in order to find the
probability that X is between
this range, we take the
probability that it's less
than Y squared, which
is everything here.
And then we subtract that
probability that it's less
than Y, negative Y. So what
we're left with is just within
this range.
So these actually are now
exactly CDFs of X. So this is
F of X evaluated at Y squared
and this is F of X evaluated
at negative Y. So now we've
completed step three.
And the last step that we need
to do is differentiate.
So if we differentiate both
sides of this equation with
respect to Y, we'll get that the
left side would get what
we want, which is the PDF of
Y. Now we differentiate the
right side--
we'll have to invoke
the chain rule.
So the first thing that we do
is, well, this is a CDF of X.
So when we differentiate
we'll get the PDF of X.
But then we also have invoke
the chain rule for this
argument inside.
So the derivative of Y
squared would give us
an extra term, 2Y.
And then similarly this would
give us the PDF of X evaluated
at negative Y plus the chain
will give us an extra term of
negative 1.
So let's just clean this
up a little bit.
So it's 2y F X squared plus F
X minus Y. All right, so now
we're almost done.
We've differentiated.
We have the PDF of Y, which
is what we're looking for.
And we've written it in terms
of the PDF of X. And
fortunately we know what that
is, so once we plug that in,
then we're essentially done.
So what is the PDF?
Well, the PDF of X evaluated at
Y squared is going to give
us 1 over square root of
2 pi e to the minus--
so in this case, X
is Y squared--
so we get Y to the
fourth over 2.
And then we get another 1 over
square root of 2 pi e to the
minus Y squared over 2.
OK, and now we're almost done.
The last thing that we
need to take care of
is, what is the range?
Now remember, it's important
when you calculate out PDFs to
always think about the ranges
where things are valid.
So when we think about this,
what is the range where this
actually is valid?
Well, Y, remember is related
to X in this relationship.
So as we look at this, we see
that Y can never be negative.
Because no matter what X is, Y
gets transformed into some
non-negative version.
So what we know is that this is
now actually valid only for
Y greater than 0 and for Y less
than 0, the PDF is 0.
So this gives us the
final PDF of Y.
All right, so it seems like at
first when you start doing
these derived restriction
problems
that it's pretty difficult.
But if we just remember that
there are these pretty
straightforward steps that we
follow, and as long as you go
through these steps and do them
methodically, then you
can actually come up with
the solution for
any of these problems.
And one last thing to remember
is to always think about what
are the ranges where these
things are valid?
Because the relationship between
these two random
variables could be pretty
complicated and you need to
always be aware of when things
are non-zero and
when they are 0.